americans are beginning to fight back
against the left's vaccine
enforcers knocking on their doors and
trying to collect
their personal information
who are you thank you who are you how
did you get in this building
how did you get in this building who are
you what are you doing here
we are looking support for the um
you don't have a right to be in this
building asking people it's a it's a
violation of people's hipaa rights
okay you don't have a right to be here
you get out of this building now
you're violating people's privacy rights
get out get out now
good for her as they mumble and shuffle
away
the white house calls people like these
these folks in the yellow vest that
happens to be in los angeles
a very necessary tool in their arsenal
to fight quote politicizing the vaccine
and stopping big governments you guessed
it newest enemy
misinformation we have to be very
careful and we are mindful of being
quite careful of not politicizing
the effectiveness of vaccines we have
empowered engaged
funded local voices because they are
often the most trusted voices
doctors medical experts clergy
you know people who are members of civic
leaders and communities
that's where we are putting most of our
resources
okay they're not politicizing it we
don't know exactly who the white house
is funding or
empowering but we do know that some of
the quote
trusted messengers knocking on americans
doors they're not doctors
pastors and leaders fauci and friends
are making him out to be
in fact this week we showed you how the
trusted messengers in north carolina who
are gathering information and giving out
shots at your door were largely democrat
political operatives belonging to groups
like action
nc and we showed a bunch of other groups
in other states
involved in similar efforts all
left-wing groups
which calls into question what exactly
are they doing
with all the data they're collecting and
as it turns out this is much more
widespread than we initially thought
it's not just happening as we said in
north carolina
these vaccivists seem to be targeting
swing states hmm so convenient
under the guise of protecting the
community they've been spotted in states
like georgia
florida wisconsin and many others
but don't worry cnn says
this is a non-partisan effort
quote this group this group in georgia
learned their canvassing skills in the
political arena
they've volunteered for years with the
randolph county democrat
committee earlier this year the group
wanted to build on momentum from the
2020 election
and launch the program's non-partisan
vaccine effort from democrat canvasser
to non-partisan vaccine messenger
what an interesting career path let me
ask you a question
when is a democrat operative ever done
something out of the kindness of their
heart
and who is paying for this probably you
and me and why should we believe that
this is a movement to protect the
community and not a large
scale ground campaign ahead of midterm
and presidential elections speaking of
long-term and large scope
ground campaigns let's talk to karl rove
former white house deputy chief of staff
and a fox news contributor
carl each day we learn more and more
whether it's the the talking points they
have at the door whether it's the states
that they're
in whether it's the causes they
otherwise fight for and they always seem
to line up
states that matter left-wing groups
pushing vaccines
yeah this is disturbing look i'm in
favor of
outreach efforts we've got to be able to
take these these life-saving vaccines
across the country but it ought to be
done entirely outside of politics done
by doctors and
nurses and health educations and people
drawn from health education programs at
colleges and
the scouts and service groups and
churches and
and local leaders it shouldn't be
politics that action north carolina is
an
intensely left-wing very ideological and
very active political group
go to their website it starts with a
gigantic uh
call on on the readers of the website to
demand that senators tillis and uh
and burr both republicans uh support the
president expand government spend more
money
and in fact in their description of
their mission they say their mission is
to grow
political power and yet they are somehow
involved
and it's shady are we using taxpayer
dollars we're certainly using taxpayer
dollars to pay for
yeah that we're but look we do know this
we're using taxpayer dollars
to pay for the vaccines and the support
services so are are we in essence
subsidizing a political organization in
between elections
you mentioned randolph county georgia
bobby jenkins the long time chair has
got a
neighbor to neighbor canvassing
organization and that's what is
openly doing the work in randolph county
if
if you're in the white house and you're
attempting to solve this problem
do you really want to pollute it with a
big draw up of
highly partisan and ideological groups
rather than focusing on the mission at
hand
and you're also right where are these
people around in let's say nebraska
are these people around and let's say
rhode island
are these people around in new mexico uh
are these people around in uh in in
say oregon no no you're right it appears
like
they're mainly active in fact the list
i've seen is virtually
only states that are swing states close
states from the 2020 election
somebody in the white house and somebody
at the department of health and human
services
has to be held to account who's making
these decisions
who's allowing politics to enter into
something that ought to be as far away
from politics as
possible it's a great point carl it it
feels like it's a convenient twofer
right you're doing the the covet vaccine
effort and you're gathering data
you would know is
oh gosh think about it think about it
think about it
you can you go to randolph county
georgia and you stick a needle in the
arm
and then you come back a year later and
say now just remember
we from the randolph county democrat
neighbor to neighbor program came by
and took care of you and then you need
to respond by by voting democrat
you're action north carolina we the
progressives building political power
we're back on your doorstep remember
reminding you that we were here last
year with a life-saving vaccine
interesting
who has got this data where is this data
being shared and why are they allowing
expressively expressly political groups
to be involved how can we get that
answer
how can we get the answer of who's
funding it or is it too obscured through
the ways bureaucracy pay groups and
public-private partnerships and how
could we get that answer
now look first of all you know if some
of these states like georgia have
republican governors they ought to be
demanding answers
because my gut tells me that that they
have reached out to state departments of
health
to be involved in these programs we need
to have members of congress in all of
these battleground states
that are they're having these kind of
programs raise questions and demand
answers
from the secretary of health and human
services and from the white house
who is in charge of this program and and
and we also ought to challenge the media
all of the media to go out there imagine
what would happen if this were
a year and a year ago and donald trump
was using the republican party
organization or the american
conservative union
or empower america or the koch brothers
americans for prosperity
to deliver shots and doing so openly
look it's one thing if a bunch of
volunteers who've got a political
background show up and say
we're going to join the you know travis
county uh uh
uh medical association and in support of
this effort
it's another thing when it is openly and
actively political groups so true can
you imagine if
charlie kirk and candace owens were
showing up at your door with a bag of
needles and how the media
would respond to that i mean it's the
double standard it can't even be
it's it's it's jaw-dropping carl you're
totally right i hope
they should be asked at the press podium
tomorrow as soon as possible
where this is coming from really
appreciate your insight carl thank you
you bet thank you pete you got it